point d'orgue de cette visite du peuple
sa rencontre avec le grand ayatollah ali
sistani la plus haute autorité pour de
nombreux chiites d'irak et du monde
l'occasion de tisser de nouvelles
relations interreligieuses
selon françois xavier gicquel directeur
des opérations de sos chrétiens d'orient
et enfin l'extrême en forme parce que
c'est une des personnalités chip les
plus importantes et les plus influentes
du monde chic et et je pense que
politiquement c'est extrêmement
important d'avoir ce dialogue pour la
paix pour pour vivre ensemble et pour
espérer un avenir en commun en irak qui
est un pays qui connaît des problèmes
très importante pour la corruption mais
aussi la difficulté de vivre ensemble
pour les différentes communautés
qu'elles soient chiites sunnites ou des
minorités mais également de toutes les
autres composantes
ils sont au coeur de cette mosaïque et
l'irak les nazis ni les kaka et les
shabaks les turkmènes ont la stature du
pape qui est à la fois un chef religieux
d'une communauté extrêmement importante
mais aussi un chef d'état qui arrivent
et qui parle d'égal à égal avec des
autorités politiques avec les autorités
religieuses avec les autorités civiles
en effet c'est extrêmement important
pour l'avenir à la fois des chrétiens en
irak mais je pense de la communauté
irakienne tout entière qui a besoin de
symbole d'unité pour ne pas va
rencontrer le grand ayatollah ali
sistani
donc on peut espérer que les ministres
chiites qui lui sont fidèles qui sont
plutôt des misfits nationale et
nationalistes irakienne rendre leurs
armes durant l'espace de quelques jours
histoire de garantir un peu de paix
durant ce voyage est un dialogue inter
religieux qu'ils soient internes mais je
pense que les forces de sécurité
irakienne et les forces de sécurité
kurdes sont vraiment bons sur le pont
garantir le bon déroulement de sa vie